c'est le conflit qui fait frémir
l'occident à l'est de l'europe vladimir
poutine manoeuvre à la frontière de
l'ukraine faisant craindre une
potentielle invasion de quoi raviver les
souvenirs de l'annexion de la péninsule
de crimée en 2014
signé le 10
[Musique]
mai s'ils oublient
alors poutine va t'il envahir l'ukraine
l'europe et l'occident peuvent-ils l'en
empêcher des éléments de réponse dans
facture
[Musique]
pour comprendre ce conflit il faut
remonter 30 ans en arrière à la suite de
la chute du mur de berlin les régimes
communistes tombe en europe même au sein
de l'urss les républiques périphériques
réclament leur indépendance en 1991 le
bloc soviétique s'effondre et donne
naissance à 15 états dont l'ukraine et
en ukraine certaines choses à dire la
russie déjà ces régions de l'est sont
russophones et le sentiment d'y être
ukrainien et parfois minoritaire en 2013
40 % des crimes et un se sentait et
russes et seulement 15% ukrainien en
crimée toujours il y à sébastopol où se
trouve une base navale russe historique
avec accès à la mer noire et à la
méditerranée c'est en 2014 qu'un
événement va déclencher l'escaladent
c'est la révolution de maidan elle porte
son nom de la place maïdan à kiev de
violentes manifestations qui ont eu lieu
pour protester contre la décision du
gouvernement ukrainien de ne pas
intégrer l'union européenne au profit de
la russie profitant de ce chaos la
russie annexe la crimée et vladimir
poutine fait alors cette promesse
celle ci clichy 14 doit sacrément partir
du togo les gones
pourtant le mois suivant la région du
dombass fait sécession et deux
républiques séparatistes sont créés la
république donesk et la république de
louhansk c'est ici qu'a lieu la guerre
du dombass opposant l'ukraine aux
séparatistes soutenus par moscou
récemment l' escalade est encore montée
d'un cran laissant craindre un risque
d'invasion de l'ukraine des militaires
russes ont été déployées en masse à la
frontière il serait 92000 selon le chef
des renseignements et craignant
plusieurs vidéo authentifiée par des
experts ou par nos confrères de france
info circule et témoigne du déplacement
massif de matériel militaire vers la
frontière ukrainienne en termes
d'ampleur ce n'est pas inédit il s'est
passé au plan quantitatif la même chose
au printemps de cette année la
différence
mais credit hâtives et au niveau de la
qualité des unités
d'équipements dans ce jour doté selon
l'ukraine une offensive russe est même
possible cet hiver le washington post
rapporte lui le projet d'une attaque de
l'ukraine sur plusieurs fronts avec 175
mille soldats déployés schyle une
opération de bet awards yeux alors le
duo janvier février dans ses parages le
printemps n'est pas une bonne période
pour faire la guerre
en russe lada raspoutine chat alors que
l'hiver hilda période propice pour ce
genre d'opération ces manoeuvres ont
poussé volodymyr zelensky le président
un créneau 1 à se trouver des alliés à
des shoots indeed be no doubt
12h05
[Musique]
alors à quoi joue vladimir tout y est
c'est justement l'otan le dernier point
évoqué par joe biden qui intéresse la
russie car l'ukraine cherchent à
intégrer l'organisation militaire pour
garantir sa sécurité cette manoeuvre
elle vise la part de la russie à faire
pression sur d'abord sur l'ukraine et à
travers lui traîne bien sûr à faire
pression sur les pays dit le temps
impossible pour elle d' imaginer une
traîne membres de l'otan au thalys et sa
7,7 inacceptable grâce à ces
intimidations poutine a gagné
l'attention des états unis il a renvoyé
quelques milliers de troupes massées
près de l'ukraine dans leurs
casernements et a fait des propositions
dans deux textes un traité avec les
états unis et une série de mesures avec
le temps à l'intérieur se trouvent les
volontés russe
[Musique]
les etats unis ne doivent pas établir de
bases militaires dans les pays de
l'ancienne union soviétique non membres
de l'otan ou développer une coopération
militaire bilatérale avait que
tous les membres de l'otan s'engagent à
s'abstenir de tout nouvel élargissement
de l'organisation y compris l'adhésion
de l'ukraine ainsi que d'autres états
alors ceux qui peuvent empêcher une
attaque contre l'ukraine ce sont les
états unis les revendications russe et
la question on craignait vont faire
l'objet de négociations entre les deux
puissances le calcul des russes et que
joe biden personnellement qui reconnut
la guerre froide la fremm et qui sans
doute n'a pas très envie de dire venir
et qui a d'autres chats à fouetter
notamment en asie peut-être que joe
biden et sa ministre à sion sur ont
finalement plus réceptif à une forme de
realpolitik des européens qui
finalement sont plus grande politique
qui parle de principes de valeurs et
puis c'est tout alors que vont donner
ces discussions la première hypothèse
c'est celle du compromis si les états
unis ne devrait pas accepter les
demandes de la russie en l'état il y a
une base pour négocier personne n'a
envie d'intégrer
l'ukraine et la géorgie formellement
dans l'auto en tout simplement parce que
personne n'a envie de risquer un conflit
nucléaire avec la russie or c'est ce qui
se passerait
imaginez que l'ukraine fasse partie de
l'otan aujourd'hui les escarmouches dans
basse ça peut en quelques minutes virer
au conflit nucléaire donc à la fin du
monde tout simplement pour éviter cela
la russie pourrait faire une proposition
que les états unis pourraient considérer
que le cren respecte les accords de
minsk signé en 2015 ils doivent mettre
fin à la guerre dans le donbass mais
n'ont jamais été appliquées dans la
seconde hypothèse si aucun accord n'est
trouvé on risquerait alors une escalade
si le scénario de l'invasion de
l'ukraine devrait être écarté vladimir
poutine a d'autres néanmoins deux
scénarios intermédiaires qui doit être
pris au sérieux en ukraine même peut y
avoir par exemple des frappes des
frappes sur des base aérienne ou des
frappes où sont déployés ces drones turc
par exemple ça peut être aussi l'annoncé
du déploiement en europe dans la partie
européenne de la russie de missiles à
portée intermédiaire parce que ça ne
concerne directement encore une fois les
missiles en question ils vont pas
jusqu'à washington ils sont sur paris
sur bernard fragneau capital à ses
discussions avec les états unis sont
attendues depuis longtemps par la russie
et il aura fallu des manoeuvres
militaires pour qu'elles se produisent
en attendant l'ukraine et l'union
européenne sont spectateurs